bonsoir la mémoire et la honte pour
commémorer le 50e anniversaire de la
rafle du veldi François mitéran a déposé
cet après-midi une gerbe une cérémonie
de souvenir à l'endroit où 13000 juifs
des hommes des femmes et des enfants ont
été parqués plusieurs jours dans des
conditions effroyables avant d'être
déporté les quelques très rares escapés
sont venus aujourd'hui témoigner mais 50
ans après cet anniversaire a réveillé
aussi le débat sur la responsabilité de
Vichy et de l'État et il y a eu quelques
incident image commenté par Philippe
Denis des sifflets pour le président ce
devait être une commémoration digne 50
ans après la rafle du veldive François
mitéran avait fait un geste en venant y
assister mais la moitié de l'assistance
l'a sifflé dès son arrivée la
déclaration du Président de la
République le 14 juillet selon laquelle
la République n'est pas comptable des
actes de Vichy n'est pas passé auprès
d'une partie de la communauté
juive
réaction de Robert Badinter à ses cris
la
colère je me serais attendu à tout
éprouver sauf le sentiment que j'ai
ressenti il y a un instant et que je
vous livre avec toute ma force d'homme
vous m'avez fait honte vous m'avez fait
honte en pensant à ce qui s'est passé là
vous m'avez fait honte
il y a des moments où il est dit dans la
parole les morts vous écoutent
croyez-vous cet incident aurait presque
fait oublier qu'il s'agissait de
commémorer un drame mais une femme qui a
vécu la rafle du veldive est venu la
raconter dans cette situation
effarante j'avais remarqué que la
verrière était
bleu j'aimais déjà beaucoup cette
couleur mais je ne comprenais pas
comment pouvit être associé à l'horreur
que nous vivions à ce
moment-l symboliquement c'est avec cette
femme que François mitan a déposé une
gerbe au pied de la plaque commémorative
il y a 50 ans jour pour jour ici il y
avait un vélodrome
12884 juifs ont été parqués par des
policiers français avant de partir pour
les camp de la mort